[Music]
the idyllic islands of french polynesia
may seem like a relaxing paradise of
pristine reefs and clear waters
but take a dip below the surface
are you ready for a swim
[Music]
bakarava is a rectangular shaped atoll
located in french polynesia in the south
pacific ocean
the southern pass of wakarava is known
as the grey shark wall due to having the
highest concentration of grey reef
sharks in the world
since 2006 the sharks have been
protected from fishing which is
attributed to their population increase
during the day the sharks are fairly
docile and conserve energy ready to hunt
their prey at night
although the exact number of sharks
found in vaquarava is uncertain with
only 650 human residents it's likely the
people are outnumbered
[Music]
if you're afraid of coming down and
going and swimming in the ocean because
of sharks you should be terrified
to make a piece of toast
400 people died last year from defective
toasters
whereas less than 10 did from sharks
[Music]
this is the first large shark expedition
like this in the western gulf we'll be
tagging hammerhead sharks tiger sharks
and mako sharks trying to understand how
they're leveraging the gulf in their
birthing mating and full migratory
patterns
we'll be getting up every day just
before dawn the fishing team will be
going out getting all of our lines
rigged and ready to go and then we'll
get the ship in position with a lift in
the water
and we'll be looking to capture bring
sharks back to the lift lift them up out
of the water and once we do that a whole
team of scientists from a half dozen
institutions will circle around the
shark and we'll conduct 12 research
projects in about 15 minutes then
release the shark and open source the
tracking to the world so that everyone
can follow it
what we're finding is that these massive
sharks have huge huge movements across
the ocean we have one of these white
sharks lydia who's traveled over 35 000
miles in just two years
very very regular for these sharks to be
swimming a thousand miles a month which
is why it's so important to figure out
where they go
we're losing 200 000 sharks a day for
shark fin soup 100 million a year
you know people need to understand
an ocean with no sharks means an ocean
with no fish they are the lion the
balance keeper of the ocean and if they
are not there the whole food chain
collapses
this is a simple battle we got to solve
the puzzle of these sharks lives to make
sure they flourish and make a difference
for the future
[Music]
i recently told somebody that getting
attacked by a shark was the greatest
thing that's ever happened to me they're
like that's absurd or that you know why
would you say that
i've had incredible opportunities i've
been able to visit some really cool
places meet some incredible people
all these things have been nurtured from
the shark attack
i think it's really made me who i am
today
[Music]
my name is mike cootes i live in the
island of kauai in hawaii i'm a surfer
photographer and shark attack survivor
there's some really great surf spots out
here i was 18 years old surfing here on
kauai with some friends and it was early
in the morning and i paddled out and
thought i was gonna have a surf session
like any other day and
it was a lot different i got attacked by
a tiger shark as soon as i hit it it let
go and disappeared back underwater and i
remember passing out basically as soon
as we got to the hospital and i woke up
a day and a half later an amputee
[Music]
i got my first prosthetic six months
after the shark attack
early on you think you can't do this you
think you can't do that you know there's
these physical limitations on life and
i don't think i could drive a truck with
a stick shift and you learn how to drive
a truck with a stick shift and you're
like wow that was cool and you build up
these little things like day to day
today after a while it's like bring it
on what what can happen that i can't
figure out how to do
i was in college and i remember class
got out i was like you know what i'm
gonna take a longboard i'm gonna get the
biggest board i can find and just take
my prosthetic in the water and see what
happens
i caught a wave and
i was screaming pretty loud i was like
what this is cool this is amazing and i
think that was like the best wave i had
ever caught in my life
from then on i started figuring out okay
what's gonna break what can i make
that's a foot that'll help me surf even
better and trying to basically make the
ultimate surfing foot
i think i'm doing it because it's fun
but i'm also it's this learning
experience and it's taking this
information and passing it on to people
that want to surf with a prosthetic
the ocean has taken a lot for me but
what it's given back to me has been
immeasurable i've lost you know nearly
my life to a shark yet i really believe
sharks are
one of the if not the most important
species in our marine ecosystem at the
rate that they're being killed off
they're not going to be around in 10 15
20 years and why not use something that
could i guess be said as a negative and
turn into a positive
the shark attack's been the greatest
thing that's ever happened
[Music]
i've had an absolute fascination with
sharks since i was a little kid
[Music]
[Applause]
i knew i wanted to be a marine biologist
by the time i was five and i got to
snorkel with my first shark when i was
about eight years old and i was
literally hooked on these awesome
animals
i'm jillian morris i am a shark
conservationist a shark diver and an
underwater videographer
[Music]
i've traveled all over the world and i
have to say that bimini has some of the
bluest waters i've ever seen all
different shades some people joke about
the fifty shades of blue in bimini the
island is really really small it's about
six miles long but
the world just below the surface is
really what's incredible that blue
crystal clear water is teeming with
marine life and is the reason why we
live on this tiny little island
the great hammerhead dive site is about
a quarter of a mile offshore it's a
place where in very shallow water you're
able to get in and see these very large
sharks up close and personal
it's very rare to actually be able to be
in the water with so many of them like
we can here in bimini especially in
crystal clear shallow water
unfortunately sharks get a really bad
reputation they're not man-eating
monsters they're not mindless eating
machines they're actually really
intelligent social incredible animals
they're also really incredible for the
health of our oceans which all of us
rely on every single day
there's something really special about
hammerheads i've been in the water with
some very big sharks including great
whites and tiger sharks but nothing
compares to the great hammerhead the way
they move
their power their grace they can turn on
a dime and they have those wide set eyes
they're my favorite animal on the planet
and being able to dive with them as much
as we do
i feel really really lucky
i remember the first time i jumped in i
was scared to death
you know that it has the the power to
mangle you in a second
but it chooses not to and that
fascinates me
[Music]
my name is andreas b haider i'm a sailor
adventurer and marine biologist from
norway
this is my third season in northern
norway where i spend the winter with my
post barba
it's harsh and it's
also tremendously beautiful there is
no sign of of people to me it's nature
at its very best
our goal for this season is to make a
documentary about
orcas and whales in the wild
what makes interaction with orca so
special is that you know that it's the
apex predator of the sea this has a
tremendous power
often we have to observe them from
distance and at some points they are
relaxed and you can approach them and
that's when you get them playful
they're so gentle yet so fast and
they're so powerful yet so very calm and
peaceful
to me these whales and the era they're
in they're kind of the pinnacle of
interacting with nature once you've made
eye contact with anorca there is no
turning back it's a moment you never
forget
[Music]
welcome to hanson island a remote place
on the west coast of canada about 10
kilometers long and two kilometers wide
this island belongs to two groups
the first nations
and the orca
for most of my life i've had the great
good fortune of living here in this
incredible environment and studying this
incredible creature and it's given me
a sense of peace in the world
i want everybody to have that same
experience
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is paul spong and 47 years ago i
was a young scientist at the university
of british columbia and part of my job
was to study an orca in captivity at the
vancouver aquarium
i came to understand that orcas are
acoustic creatures because they're using
sam to locate their prey
they get what they need to live from
sound they should not be penned up in
concrete tanks it deprives them of the
sound of the ocean that they were born
into
ultimately that knowledge led me to
search for a place in the wild where i
could study orcas totally without
interfering with them and that search
led me to hansen island where i set up
orca lab
we built a network of half a dozen
hydropons that cover 50 square
kilometers of the surrounding area
and they give us live audio so we can
track their movements often 24 hours a
day
61 and 60 are right
for me one of the greatest experiences
here is putting on a pair of earphones
and just listening
and then we have speakers in the forest
near the tents near the art house near
the camp kitchen all of the spaces
around here
one of the things you can't help
noticing and feeling is the sudden
intrusion of a boat of a vessel a little
propeller it's jarring
[Applause]
[Music]
here at orca lab we listen to untold
quantities of boat noise it's really
annoying
we can always walk away from it but
whales can't
it disrupts their communication it
disrupts their ability to hunt i've had
quite a few breaches as well
i think from a point of view of the
welfare of the whales something that has
to be dealt with
what i want to do is develop the ability
for people to get to feel empathy for
the creature
since 2000 we've streamed live audio so
that anybody with computer access to the
internet can listen to exactly what we
listen to in our lab
[Music]
what we're trying to do is give people a
taste of what it is
to be an orca in this magnificent
environment
in doing that they will come to care and
want to protect nature
i believe that if i can share what i
have experienced the world could know
peace
[Music]
you